and now I want to show you unfortunately
a video from The View I thought maybe we
could take a day off but then this uh
Anna Navarro she does not like Elon Musk
and uh she is blaming him for you people
thinking differently than she does
I I joined too because it's not owned by
Elon Musk and that in itself is enough
for me to join I you know I just I don't
understand how somebody with us much
money as Elon Musk as many children as
Elon Musk has many projects as Elon Musk
can be so have so much time to be
trolling and spreading hate and
misinformation on this platform that
went from going downhill to going right
off the cliff you know I mean this guy
can he just maybe go to space do you
stay there do you think you know I mean
I just I you know I I I I hate what's
happening to Twitter because I think
Twitter has done a lot of good I think
there's a lot of movements around the
world that have happened because of of
Twitter and it's you know it's done a
lot of good it's also done a lot of bad
and um but he has no intention of
stopping the lies and the misinformation
the the incredible condescending tone
and resentment she has or probably the
most important person that is on Earth
right now someone that is literally
trying to get us to do interplanetary
travel someone who's doing a hell of a
lot for the environment someone who is
buying a thing like Twitter which is
losing a ton of money bought it for
what was it a cool 45 billion dollars
knowing it was losing a crazy amount of
money but he bought it because he wanted
to defend Free Speech misinformation was
being peddled left and right all over
Twitter and censorship was running
rampant Oliver Twitter Hunter Biden's
story for example the laptop you
couldn't even share it on your private
DMS New York Post got banned on Twitter
even though it now has all turned out to
be true he came in and said hey we will
defend the principles of Free Speech but
there is an entire
machine devoted to making you think that
truth and questions and curiosity and
thinking about the world in a different
way is all bad and negative and is hate
and you can see it whether it's Anna
Navarro you can see it whether it's Joy
read or it's Karin Jean-Pierre or
virtually anybody that is part of the
machine at this point the I also what
she says the condescending tone he has
all this money he has all these children
he has all these projects like yeah so
he's trying to defend Free Speech
Because he believes in the future right
his kids he could put them all on a
rocket and get them all off this Rock
right now he's probably thinking about
it because of you morons
[Music]
thank you